now have these last three uh and only
two can go through and we find out the
name in about eight minutes time yeah
eight minutes time and look at the
results from last time richie sunak
topping the pole of mps he got 118. he
was just a couple shy of that magic 120
line so do you think it's almost a given
that he's going to go through he does
look likely to go through but i'm not
putting my money anywhere certainly not
10 minutes or so before the result but
the big question is can liz trust she's
underperformed in quite a few of those
mp voting rounds can she leap into
second place and therefore get a chance
to throw herself in front of the members
and see what they make of her and that's
important isn't it because that is where
it's going to go now we've had these
kind of almost roller coaster rides of
mp votes almost on a daily basis
whittling their list down but after
today it's going to go to the members
and it does look uh we are getting some
indications what the members think so
there's 160 170 000 of them out in the
country they're going to get an
opportunity to vote electronically some
of them will vote by post and so uh we
could actually see really many people
making up their mind by say the fifth
sixth seventh tenth of august so i think
the critical bit will last another
couple of weeks and what the members
polling has shown us is that
well if you look at this trust she may
have been behind amongst mps for much of
this race but she going to yesterday's
snap you guys story members poll would
be rishi sumac would beat penny morden
so uh
so liz trust there in you know in a good
position at the moment team sunac
suggests that actually what you're
seeing over the last couple of weeks is
the gap closing between particularly liz
trust uh and richie sooner there was a
bigger lead uh maybe 10 days ago that
has now come down but there's no doubt
that it's going to be a fraud contest
one of the arguments being used by penny
morgan's campaign is you look at the way
that liz trust and richard sooner have
treated each other all the briefing from
allies of liz trust at richard cena and
penny morton or just look at the debate
on sunday night where uh you had rishi
soon at former chancellor calling liz
trust a socialist and suggesting that
she engaged in fantasy economics
that if you have rishi sooner and liz
trust in the final two then you really
are going to see quite a dirty race um
and that's going to do lasting damage to
the conservative party it was quite
interesting wasn't it at prime
minister's questions today boris
johnson's final uh pmq's as uh prime
minister um kim stanley's attack lines
were written for him he literally just
picked three questions reeling off a
series of quotes from the three
candidates in the race effectively
trashing the government i think there's
no doubt that labour had been a winner
of the last couple of weeks of
leadership contest they put out a social
media video yesterday which was simply
bits of sunday night's debate clipped
together that's why there was some i
think fright amongst the candidates
that's why uh liz trust pulled out of
the sky news debate on uh
last night gosh time flies on tuesday
night because of the damage that some of
these discussions some of these
arguments are doing to the various
candidates okay thanks very much uh sam
well we're gonna go now and talk to our
politician beth rigby who's been
following every twist and turn of this
leadership fair contest and beth it does
feel quite remarkable still just how
unpredictable it is
it really is such a tight rate for race
for that second place and i've been
calling around in the last hour trying
to get a sense of where the teams think
they are
and in t morden there is a mix of
concession
from one of her backers saying they
think liz has edged it another has just
texted me to say they think liz trust
might have edged it another says the
numbers are going to be very tight
but they're still positive
on the mordant camp so it is so tight
between these two women liz truss and
penny mordant who will edge it uh into
the final two uh and face rishi sunak
in that runoff which will go over the
summer as the two final contenders go
around the country
giving
their pitch to conservative party
members are 200 000 of them so also who
will decide uh who will be their party
leader and the next prime minister but i
have to say as sam was talking about in
terms of that attack video from labour
and what we saw from kierstama in prime
minister's questions there is a sense uh
from many mps i've spoken to that they
think a rishi sunak liz trust runoff is
going to be bad news for the
conservative party with these two very
senior uh conservative figures taking
slugs out of each other with liz trust
attacking rishi sanak's economic record
and rishi sunak
attacking liz trust for what he
describes as fantasy economics that is
not really the vision of conservatism
that the country perhaps would find
attractive when it comes to going to the
polls so i think a lot of conservatives
are worried about the next few weeks and
the longer term damage it could create
on the tory brand
you certainly were touching on that in
your analysis for prime minister's
questions as well with those tap lines
from kia stammer we're currently looking
at pictures of the committing room where
the chair of the 1922 committee sergeant
brady is going to be entering at 4
o'clock we expect
giving his verdict on the vote and beth
i just wonder how difficult it is to
call partly because it feels like as all
mps seem to be saying a very
untrustworthy electorate do you think
there might be a bit of skullduggery
going on in previous rounds
well that's certainly been the
discussion overnight uh with mps there's
different camps there's different
theories about whether or not rishi
sonak's lending votes to different teams
in order to keep a favored candidate in
or out who does he think it's easier to
face in a runoff i actually put that to
chris skidmore one of his backers and a
former minister yesterday on sky news
and chris skidmore told me that he
thought that rishi sunat would feel his
trust most in any
leadership runoff because then it would
be a battle for ideas and perhaps
for rishi sunak he might feel that going
up against penny mordant on the issue of
competence given that that's what some
senior
cabinet ministers have raised around
penny morden none less than anne marie
trevelyan who's not backing her but was
her boss at the department of trade and
marie trevally actually backing liz
trust that maybe rishi sunak feels that
he could have a easier battle against
penny mordant because he could perhaps
over the weeks to come take her apart a
bit on the matter of competence whereas
from a liz trust perspective well some
of rishi sunak's allies saying to me
that liz trust could go up against
russia soon i can say you might be a
slicker operator and a proposition you
might
telegenically have it a bit more over me
but i list trust i'm the real tory and
the real tax cutter that's going to be
quite a difficult battle for rishi sunak
against conservative mps not least
because as you saw in the commons
earlier boris johnson taking quite a
clear dig
rishi sunak there saying to mps my
advice for any successor would be try to
deregulate and cut taxes well if that
wasn't an endorsement for liz trust i
don't know what was
yeah certainly it did feel like that way
didn't it and one minute to go now if
they are running on time you can see
that room filling up a few fans out it's
actually pretty warm uh here in the
palace of westminster i have to say and
beth it feels worth reflecting on just
how different the candidates are still
left in the race we could be seeing a
very different type of prime minister
depending on who wins today
yeah i mean there's different offers
there
liz trust is obviously the most
continuity boris johnson she was loyal
to him she didn't stand down she wants
to deregulate she wants lower taxes
she's positioned herself as the true
brexiteer she's pushing through the
northern ireland protocol through the
house of commons rishi sunak uh is sort
of standing on a pitch of integrity
and uh competence and then penny mordant
really has positioned herself as the
change candidate saying i wasn't really
part of the boris johnson government but
i'm the one that can connect most with
the public but there's a question here
about when they actually get into power
whichever it may be how much really can
they change the mandate if they don't
call a general election they've got a
mandate from 2019 to implement a
manifesto but they don't have a mandate
much beyond that i think what definitely
none of them have in the way that boris
johnson did is that charm some people
didn't like it some people loved it but
what you could not deny about boris
johnson was his ability to connect with
voters we've talked a bit about how he
was a heineken politician that in his
heyday he could reach parts of the
electorate that other tories couldn't
reach then he became much more marmite
people loved him still or they
absolutely
detested him and didn't like him at all
and that kind of era will be overlooked
they're coming in let's listen him
it's on blue paper
um
it's returning officer i can give you
the results of the ballot uh 357
votes were cast out of a possible 358
there were two
spoiled ballot papers
the numbers of votes cast for each
candidate is as follows
mordent
105
sunak
one three seven
truss one one three
therefore rishi sunak and liz truss
will be the candidates going forward to
a final ballast of conservative party
members
the ballot will close on the 2nd of
september and i will announce the
results at 12 30 p.m on monday the 5th
of september thank you very much
well there it is the result it was going
to be rishi sunak and liz truss who will
go through to the final stage of the
contest the two candidates and tory
party members are now going to vote on
who to be the next prime minister and
leader of their party rishi sunak
topping that poll with 137 votes liz
truss on 113 penny mordance on 105 which
means she is now eliminated well let's
go straight to our political editor beth
rigby shall we for some analysis beth
what do you make of those results
well i'm just looking at the figures
there and in terms of the final round
there really was a consolidation of
votes with liz trust the one
putting on the most votes there plus 27
from the final round it is a sonic
versus trust run off it is if you like
the battle of ideas for the direction of
the conservative party is it more
of trying to cut inflation and then cut
taxes or is it a more blue-blooded liz
trust deregulatory pitch in which she
begins to cut taxes now a real battle
for ideas between these two candidates
and as for penny mordant well she was
eight short of liz trust such a tight
race if just four mps had changed their
minds the votes could have fallen a
different way she put on 13 from the
last ballot she will no doubt be
absolutely devastated she led didn't she
up to this round and liz trust overtaken
her there but in terms of the wider
party for rishi sunak i think this is a
more difficult contender for him in that
liz truss is the foreign secretary she
too has cabinet experience and she will
give a different version of conservatism
to rishi sunak crucially as well for liz
tras she was the one that
did not uh leave cabinet did she did not
resign she stayed loyal to boris johnson
now that might have been uncomfortable
for her uh in the uh hours when dozens
of colleagues were leaving government
but in terms of the party membership
many of whom
are still big fans of boris johnson it
will help her so i think in terms of
that too uh rishi sunak is going to have
a hard battle against liz trust in terms
of winning over party members what did
rishi sanat want to do well look at the
figures how far ahead of it is i'll try
and do this quickly in my head he's 30
something votes 34
votes ahead of liz truss now in terms of
that he wanted to put clear blue water
between her and himself in order to try
and portray to party members um that he
uh was really the part the choice of mps
and that he really will be the more
competent candidate but look it's the
foreign secretary versus the former
chancellor it's going to be a very very
very punchy race and i imagine that
there's going to be a lot of attacks
over the weekend and i would also
imagine that there will be more dirty
tricks in this runoff and it could be
quite unpleasant yet with lots of rumors
swirling around about dark arts and
attack jobs and each of the candidates
uh thank you beth just stay there we've
got a tweet from pennymorden she's
tweeted to say thank you to everyone for
all your hard work we go forward
together and how difficult do you think
it's going to be beth though going
forward together you were just alluding
to there that relationship
between rishi sunak and liz trust
they've been frankly tearing strips off
each other so far in the race do you
think it's going to affect the tone of
the contest over the summer
well just in terms of the attacks that
they have put on each other in the past
to leadership debates
rishi sunak i should say he's 24 votes
ahead of liz trust he has attacked her
fantasy economics she has attacked him
saying where's your growth plan been for
the past two and a half years she's
talked about
a recession caused by economic policy
she's criticized him for creating the
highest tax economy that britain has
seen for 70 years i mean this is not
good in terms of the wider conservative
brand because as brandon lewis the
former northern ireland secretary was
writing in the times earlier this week
divided parties do not win elections
these blue one blue attacks trash in the
record of the previous administration
only serves to put doubt into the voters
minds about the focus uh of the
government and indeed their competence
and i think given what's happened with
boris johnson and the infighting
questions of competence and delivery
will be very important
to voters who are dealing with a cost of
living crisis you've seen inflation is
now at its highest since february 1992
and while people are worrying about that
and making ends meet they're watching
the government
indulge if you like some would say in a
leadership contest in which they're
going to get a new prime minister that
they didn't directly elect in 2019 and
who will say that they have a mandate to
continue to serve for the remainder of
this parliamentary term so it would be
very interesting to see
on monday when the two leaders or the
two candidates rather go up in against
each other in a bbc televised debate it
would be very interesting to see about
how the tone might change and whether or
not these attacks on each other uh
dissipate a little because once this is
all over the party will have to come
back together and you can see that in
terms of the
mps they have literally split three
waves almost between these three
candidates that is a very very divided
party and whoever wins is going to have
one hell of a job to bring this
conservative party back together and to
make it governable once again because it
certainly hasn't been in recent weeks
uh thank you very much for your analysis
sir beth quickly bethlehem
and i just want to put some of those
points that beth was making to our next
guest serene duncan smith who's
supporting
liz trust well firstly you must be
delighted with the result yeah i'm very
pleased uh our candidate liz trust put
on 27 extra which was the biggest growth
of all of the three candidates
and she's through now to the round with
the public to the members so that's very
good news he's bought a very good
campaign i'm
sorry the others have fallen out we're
all conservatives at the end of the day
i hope we'll all come back together
again and just get on the government as
and when whoever wins the final round
you just say you know there that we're
all conservatives we need to kind of
pull together and beth ruby was just
making the point that i guess liz trust
and russia sunak have really been
getting stuck into each other a little
bit in those tv debates that whoever
wins is gonna have in her words a hell
of a job turning it around we always say
that i've done seven of these one two
and one one myself and everybody always
says will you come back together again
and almost always we come back together
again i mean these debates are big
debates and i think the public has a
right to hear them what are you going to
do about helping people who are
suffering from the cost of living crisis
should we get taxes down do we need to
have such high taxes i don't think so
these are big debates that the public
needs to see us and recognize we're
passionate about and we may disagree on
some of these things but at the end of
the day we have one person all
conservatives want to get the basic tax
down the question is when do you do it
but you also will acknowledge as you
know you are you know a veteran if you
like some of these uh debates that there
have been a personal attacks i mean you
for example have been uh you know told
me about penny morgan what's she done
for the last few years we've seen lord
frost for example questioning her
competence there have been clearly a tax
made they're not personal attacks if you
ask i want to know i mean i
judged everybody on what their record
was in government over two and a half
years you had two and a half years to
deliver brexit get things done who did
the most who actually managed to get
those across the line and i went to lose
trust because she had the strongest
record on me
my question about penny morton was i
don't know what she's done she needs to
be clear about what her successes and
failures were how did she battle things
over that's all so just a reasonable
question that's not an attack on anybody
do you think the tone of the debates
will soften in the months ahead over
some of them well i think they'll be uh
they're going to be tight because uh
it's a very important job and the
direction of the party and the country
will depend on who wins it so
my view is that they will be quite
fierce
but i don't think they're going to get
personal i don't think you know i would
advise everybody
policy yes
debates about how you do stuff but stay
off the personal stuff on the policy
though we now have two very very
different visions of how the uk should
be run uh on the ballot paper don't we
we have uh rishi sunak and liz krast and
if you look at everything from taxation
to spending you can't be ending up with
two very different visions of britain
well there are differences but their
differences really of emphasis and of
timing
even rishi soon act says he wants to
bring taxes down but he doesn't believe
you do it now i disagree with him i
think he's got the headroom to do it liz
believes that
there are economic commentators out
there that actually agree with us and
some that agree with him
this is a serious debate to be had
because people's lives depend on what we
now do so i think these are legitimate
debates
the whole conservative party wants to
bring the base of taxation down the
question is when and how you do it which
is what's going to be debated
what i do want to ask you now is that
the next prime minister is going to be
decided by conservative party members
somewhere between 160 000 or 200 000
people right
whoever wins should they not call a
general election so they then have a
mandate to implement their vision which
as we know is going to be quite
different from the mandate the manifesto
no because
we don't have a presidential system here
so we have a parliamentary system
the prime minister is only the leader of
the party while he holds their
confidence
you've had this going down hundreds of
years where they don't hold their
confidence they have to go and somebody
else who has the confidence of the
political party that was elected in this
case conservatives
has a right to see out that term so i
don't think a general election is either
wanted or warranted what we need to do
is go to the next period for two years
have the election then people can judge
us on what we've done after we lost
two and a half years because of the
covid crisis now we have to get those
things sorted out
be madness to go to an election i know
some people will say oh an election tour
people want elections all the time some
people but the answer is you need
stability right now and that's what this
is all about how concerned are you that
as the country faces the cost of living
crisis you know there's a war in ukraine
and now we really have a bit of a vacuum
in august as british sooner and liz
trust slug it out
well there's lots that can be done right
now by the government still run by boris
johnson there's huge things they've got
on their agenda they can do and there's
lots they can do to help people out in
the meantime
this debate will come to fruition at the
end of august and what will happen is a
new administration but now with a
different type of energy and focused on
the things that we want the decisions
about taxation are what this is really
all about
how do we make the most out of brexit
get the regulations down get the base of
taxation down get the economy growing
you mustn't have this economy going to
recession it'd be utter disaster with
high interest rates so that is where we
go now that's a debate worth having and
i certainly am looking forward to it
talk about high interest rates that you
blame risky scenic partially uh i blame
i blame the
the government of the bank of england
really because i think they took their
eye off the ball they were printing
money a year ago
which was ridiculous and inflationary
and they didn't do interest rates do i
blame the treasury in part
because uh they shouldn't have signed
off on the
on the monetary on the explosion of qe
which took place it should have been
stopped but
these are judgment calls they'll all
come up in the course of the debate just
finally it was really quite tight at the
end wasn't it between liz trusts and
penny morgan can you give us a bit of an
insight into what the last 24 hours has
been like at hustling up support
well you know here you see everybody
face to face so
um everybody who is not sure would have
been seen they might have been seen by
liz trust or by being mordent or by
wishy sunak
and then one by one they decide what
they're going to do and they do it some
people don't always tell the truth most
do and that's how it is so it's been
hard draft
and uh and i think liz was always coming
from behind
she put on 27 votes which is a very
significant proportion
and is now in the in round two and i
think that's that's great because it
means we have a proper debate now okay a
proper debate uh certainly in dr thank
you very much for your uh reaction there
in douglas smith former leader of the
conservative party uh liz trump's
supporter clearly pretty happy to see
his
preferred choice to the ex-prime
minister making
well joining us next from east london is
patrick english for uh thank you very
much very much for being on the program
and patrick it's now over to the
conservative party members isn't it
you've been doing some polling recently
taking the temperature of where their
heads are at who do you think would win
the race between rishi sooner and
there's trust now we know the final two
well certainly right now our polling is
suggesting that as it stands this trust
has about a 20 point leave a lead over
rishi sunap heading into any sort of
contest so she said that certainly has a
lot to do his position improved somewhat
in between the poem that we managed to
publish yesterday and the polling from
last week but certainly right now we
would say that liz trust is the front
runner among conservative party members
how volatile a group
are they because it does feel as if
there's been lots of fluctuations uh
even in the last week or so
about who their preferred candidate
oh 100 absolutely so in the most recent
polling this trust appeared to have the
upper hand particularly in those
head-to-heads the time before that penny
morden was a clear favor amongst certain
party members and then just a week
before that it was ben wallace flash
back to january rishi sunac was the one
who was way ahead with the membership
and this trust was in his way so
certainly this is a very volatile
membership certainly i would say it's
all to play for but heading into the
contest heading into the summer is this
trust who does have that have that upper
hand according to our figures
it always looked like rishi soon act was
going to make it onto the final ballot
do you think he's got an easier or a
more difficult opponent at facing liz
trust than he would have if penny morden
got through
well certainly according to our polling
liz trust is a more difficult candidate
for richie sunak
if we look at the head-to-heads we
published yesterday liz trust as i say
had a 20-point lead over mushy sunak if
you look at penny morning that league
was cut down to 15 and richie sunak
improved his position over penny morgan
considerably in between those two poles
so i think if looking ahead richard cena
will probably should rather have placed
penny more than the runoff liz trust
probably is a stronger candidate films
have to face in that regard yes
and i'm not sure if this is something
that you've looked into but are there
any specific issues that you think which
cena could have to deal with uh if he is
to have a shot at winning over the
conservative party membership are they
for example
a group of people who tend to be worried
about you know taxation or the economy
or spending what is it
absolutely so we've been asking
conservative members what it is that
they really want from their next leader
and the next prime minister and the next
person to take on kirsh dharma the next
general election and what they've been
telling us is that they want a return to
sort of conventional conservatism so
that's things like cutting tax and
spending and i think at the moment
perhaps one thing that's holding rishi
soon at back is his let's say lukewarm
commitment to cutting taxes certainly at
the moment he's saying he wants to get
control of inflation first and then
think about cutting taxes whereas all of
the other candidates were offering tax
cutting platforms so i think certainly
that's an area that might be hurting
with membership right now and he might
need to look at that and see what he can
do in terms of making a different kind
of offer but yes they are looking at tax
and spending they're also looking at
things like returning to honesty and
integrity and having a strong
personality so there are other things
that the candidates could choose to
campaign on but taxing and spending and
in general kind of return to that
conventional conservatism is a popular
theme that we're getting from the
conservative members that we're polling
right now
and how different an electorate are they
from the public at large because it is
interesting isn't it that a relatively
small group of people effectively get to
choose the next prime minister
yes it is indeed they are as will not be
surprising at all quite a different
tribe to the general republic at large
the general public is very split on
whether there should be tax cuts versus
uh more spending on public services or
property funding i guess public services
whereas the conservative party members
are much more in favor of tax cuts so it
is a very uh let's say a niche
electorate to be appealing to and i
think the candidates will have to think
about that as the campaign start to draw
to a close and perhaps members will
start thinking about that as well it's
all very well and good appealing
directly to the membership but if those
pictures are going directly against the
grain of public opinion in the general
public and the voting public at large
that might run them into some trouble
looking ahead to the general election so
i think what we might expect to see is
perhaps some heads turn toward the
general public and some of the debates
turn toward maybe sort of wider economic
issues and cost of living
will go down so so very well and the
public are desperate to hear about in a
minute as the campaign goes on
okay interesting south pacific english
there or
yoga
now i have a bit of reaction to bring
you because liz trust has released a
statement off the back of her
victory her progression into the next
round she said i would like to thank
each and every one of my colleagues who
have supported me throughout this stage
of the contest i would also like to pay
tribute to every candidate who stood for
leadership each of them has contributed
enormously to the conservative party and
public life i'm excited to now take to
the country to make the case to the
conservative party about my new bold
economic plan that will cut taxes grow
our economy and unleash the potential of
everyone in our united kingdom as prime
minister i would hit the ground running
from day one unite the party and govern
in line with conservative values i am
incredibly proud to be part of the
conservative and unionist party and i'm
excited to spend the next few weeks
proving to all of our brilliant members
exactly why i am the right person to
lead it and our great nation and that
statement
from liz trusts and penny mordant as
well has tweeted this of course is
following her elimination from the
contest she's tweeted to say
thank you to everyone for all your hard
work we go forward together penny so a
short statement there from penny mordent
after she was eliminated from the race
to be the next conservative leader and
prime minister
well we're joined now by dr liam fox so
was she sunac
supporter do you think it was always a
given that he was going to end up in the
final two
i think it was likely it would end in
the final two it's a better result than
i think that uh maybe i thought this
morning and he clearly got a good
endorsement from many of those leaving
at the kemi at peternoff camp uh very
close between second and third i'm very
sorry to see penny go out she's a she's
a great person who's done so much for
the conservative party it's a good
friend of mine
and i hope that uh that should play a
part in whatever we do next but i think
it's
when you think that the mps are the
people who know the candidates best who
work with them every day uh to get a
resounding result like this but she's
unique is incredibly encouraging
and what do you make of the prospect of
lose trust they're going up against
every since we're just talking to ugarth
a little earlier who said that look
she's going to be a much harder opponent
if russia's seen out there to beat well
i think it's very important that we
actually set out and campaign for the
positive
elements of our own campaign
and those positive elements of our own
candidate and i i hope that we don't get
sort of blue on blue fighting in this
because we'll have to come together
afterwards as a party to govern the
country and i'll be supporting which
i think that we saw in the debates a
confident uh leader someone who was in
charge of
the treasury someone's across the detail
of all the different subjects not just
economics but climate or environments on
foreign policy all the things that we
will leave the prime minister to do i
look at the candidates that i have from
the beginning
not just who i want is the leader of the
conservative party who i think will make
the best prime minister who'll be able
to form a government he'll be able to
get the big tent that we need to have a
high-level cabinet that can give the
country the quality of the government
that we need and of course
we've still got two and a half years of
this parliament to run and we're still
elected on the same manifesto that we
were elected in 2019 so while we could
have differences of emphasis that we'll
still be following the main policies on
getting brexit done
concluding that process and leveling up
the country as we certainly would it's
interesting that you said that uh you
know reflecting back on the manifesto
that you did win that election or how
important do you think it is the
candidates to roughly stick to it
because you know if i look at liz
truster's policy she's talking to a bold
new economic plan it looks like she does
want a big change of direction well if
you're getting a big change you have to
ask whether you've got a mandate for
that and i think it's important that we
recognize we are elected um as a
conservative government or the manifesto
that we had so if liz trust does want to
evolve new economic plan a change of
direction do you think she should commit
to calling a general election well as i
said i'm going to
commit to the values that i think might
end up as i think he is basically to win
a general election and trump's program
would matter i think he's got the best
class for details i think the stronger
team around him and i think that in all
the areas i think he's best qualified i
think that's why he got such a
resounding book from the mps today he
did as you say get a bigger portion of
mps and it's trust but if you look at
the membership polling according to
yougov liz trust has got a 20-point lead
over rishi sooner i mean the members
don't agree with you do they yeah and if
you go back uh you had penny morton had
a big lead like kami had a
when people think back to the pandemic
and the fact that he brought in the
measures that saved millions of jobs and
saved thousands of companies going back
quite a long way to do that if you look
at the recent polling risks
that he did and very quickly we might
have a very different economic picture
than we have today unemployment may not
be at the low levels that it is neither
for the furlough scheme and the way that
he acted very quickly and decisively in
that all these things will be taken into
account i think and we'll want to see um
as he says in one of the debates if the
conservative party is not the party who
sound money what is it we can't simply
borrow more money than we're doing at
the present time much as we'd like to
raise spending in certain areas much
people like to cut taxes these things
these things have to be earned um and we
have to have sound public finances they
have to be the basis that we're going
forward
well i think you know i would put it a
different way but i if someone tells you
economic there's something that sounds
too good to be true it's probably too
good to be true okay thank you very much
indeed uh liam fox there dr liam fox uh
rishi's soon acts supporter uh talking
about the fact that we have to be he
thinks that the conservative party need
to be mindful of the mandate they were
elected on well it's now down to
conservative party members to decide who
is going to be the next party leader and
a prime minister uh our political
correspondent murray aurora is with
conservative members in waterlong thames
this afternoon how they reacted to the
result
well as you say sophie i'm here at the
walton conservative club and we know the
power is now out of mp's hands it's all
over to those vital members who'll be
making that decision this summer in the
vote so i'm here with uh harrison and
ben both tory councillors in surrey so
just give me your initial reaction when
you heard that the top two is now rishi
sunak and liz trusts
um i think i mildly expected it uh just
because you could see the momentum that
liz trust was gaining over penny i think
the questions were asked where was kemi
supporters all going to go and it's
quite clear that most of them have gone
towards uh liz uh so uh look it's it's
between the two i'm quite happy to see
rishi soon that go go through i i've
been a supporter of his and i think he's
the safest option in my opinion um but
no it's it's it's quite nice to have
some reliability now knowing who the two
are how would you feel if liz trust was
the one to win
well look i mean it's at the end of the
world i mean i'm a conservative and
she's a conservative and i think she's
raised some good policies and and i know
like i said but but i think for me rishi
sunek just seemed like the safest option
just because he has been chancellor
which in my opinion i think is as close
as you can get to that role and i think
the most pressing thing at the moment is
finances and you know cost of living
living in the economy and because he's
been in that role for the past couple of
years i think that makes him best suited
to be prime minister and ben how did you
react to the news when you found out
it's liz truss and wishy soon actually
disappointed were you over the moon uh
well i i've been a bit of a floating
voter i've been pretty undecided um but
i was actually really surprised that all
the candidates got over 100 votes so it
was a real three-way split and i think
that's going to be something that i
would hope that liz and rishi
talk about in the next little while is
how they can reunite the country and
unite the party but also what their what
their plans are for their policies and
whatnot i think
you know there is a lot of undecided
tory members out there um still and i
think it's all to play for and i think
the hustings are going to be really
important to see who comes out on top
what were your thoughts on penny warden
are you upset that she's not in the
final two
uh yeah i thought she i think she's a
she's a great candidate
and i hope she'll serve in the in the
cabinet that um under liz or rishi um i
think she's got a lot to to offer the
conservative party and in fact the whole
uh slater candidates that were came
forward in the leadership election
we have such an amazing group of talent
at the moment in the conservatives that
i hope that a lot of them will will come
into the cabinet
at high levels uh and we can
go forwards as a team and and really um
help the country and bring the country
together so you're split between rishi
sooner and liz russia are not decided
yet what would they have to do to win
your vote what would somebody say or
pledge that would say okay you've got me
yes well i i i really want a clear
strategy of of what they think what they
want to achieve in the next two years
and then going forwards beyond that um
what what they think is going to win us
the next election you know what's our
retail offer on the doorstep what are
they going to be offering the people of
great britain
as a conservative government
and i think at the moment i've heard a
bit more from rishi than i have from liz
so i'd really hope to
to learn a bit more about what each
candidate is looking at harrison you're
a rishi sunac supporter now the polling
so far suggests that if it was rishi
sunak and liz trust in the final which
we now know it is that rishi sunak would
not win and liz trust would win over him
so what do you think mashi sunak would
need to do to win over people like you
people like your colleagues who aren't
convinced by him to get over that limit
and win at the leadership election i
think you should always take polling
with a pinch assault and i think
especially this type of polling his
campaign has been pointed towards mps uh
so i think we'll see a change in
strategy slightly from rishi soon act to
maybe amy a little bit more at the
members like i said before he was trying
to convince you know his colleagues and
mps but now it's more the 160 000 people
who come to now so i think we'll
probably maybe see uh a slight change in
strategy outlining maybe exactly what
the members want to hear um and i think
that that's what we'll see and i think
we'll see a change in the polling from
that
so as you can see here at the wharton
conservative club it's still all to play
for we still don't know which way that
vote is going to go this summer and
rishi sinak although at the front the
very clear front runner in that vote for
mps that doesn't necessarily mean he's
got it in the bag when it comes to those
members so we'll have to wait and see
what the summer brings
yeah certainly uh right murray thank you
very much uh indeed for your analysis
that
well as mario was just alluding to now
of course we're entering a very
different
side of that leadership election with
the members of the people who aren't
going to decide we've been joined now by
our deputy political editor uh sam
coates and sam richardson has been the
front runner throughout so far hasn't he
do you think he can now be i guess
experiencing a bit of a different
feeling as it comes out of what it
members who are going to be deciding
well it's a sort of incredible tone of
favorite isn't it because as you say
richard sunak's been leading amongst mps
in every single round so far and yet all
of a sudden he's gone from front running
in some ways to the underdog
why do we say that well obviously
because that's 160 170 000 tory members
many of whom will vote in the next four
nights or so and the current polling
would suggest that liz trust would win
that vote 54 to 35 that was the results
of the uganda poll taken
on monday and tuesday of this week after
sunday night's debate on itv uh and just
that sense of momentum that richardson
had built up uh didn't seem to rub off
so much on the country now which is two
max teams point out that there has been
a closing gap between him uh and liz
trust in the last
week or so but it's not been uh very
much it's just been a handful of
percentage points if you drew a sort of
line it wouldn't get you uh anywhere
near where richardson needs to get
i think the thing that's harming british
zuma in this race particularly amongst
members is that there is a desire that
the way to tackle the cost of living
crisis is through tax cuts and that's
the thing that liz trust is offering but
rishi see that is not now mrs has an
argument that based on his experience at
the treasury who thinks that would be
dangerous it would take inflation
actually would make people worse off but
to what extent can candidates tell
uh particularly the membership of the
conservative party things that they
don't want to hear and that's what he's
been gambling on all the way through
this race and it's actually worked
pretty well with the mps but denying
them that i think is a potentially risky
strategy he will emphasize tax cuts
further down the line maybe next year
maybe the year after when uh an election
is even closer and when uh the public
finances are a little bit more brought
into balance but i think that a lot of
members will look at ms truss's promise
to essentially just give the nation a
bit more time to pay back its debt
and wonder why if there can be goodies
and sweeties now in return for doing
that why that isn't the preferable
option so there is this just question
how much can rishi define himself
against the membership now in this face
because it's just too much of a risk and
actually what we see is in changing tax
somehow in order to try and appeal to
the membership yeah certainly a
different group of electors as you say
sam sam was just explaining there
of course uh the 106 000 uh or so i call
the subject party members who are now
going to be choosing between two
candidates uh liz trust foreign
secretary and rishi sinak
the former uh chancellor uh there uh so
it's gonna be a very different stage of
the uh contest which you see like
clearly uh the front runner uh from at
the start when it comes to uh mps but
now of course is list trust the new
front runner well certainly if the uh
polling concept of party members is
anything to go by
then yes she
is well we're joined now uh by uh two
mps who back different people uh in the
uh contest we consider mp john lamont
who is supporting uh penny morden and
also chloe smith who is backing at liz
uh trust uh john what how disappointed
are you that your candidate didn't get
through very i mean penny uh was a real
you know she was amazing candidate but
should be an incredible prime minister
such vision and passion a real agenda
for
the whole nation and as a scottish mp
and you should speak to all parts of the
united kingdom and uh obviously very sad
that this is no longer part of the
context who would you like to win now i
don't know i'm open to persuasion so uh
i'll be listening very closely to what
liz and richie have to offer who are
also formidable and candidates we're
still lucky in this contest we have so
many talented people vying to be prime
minister of this country and i look
forward to listening to their their
policies and what they say during the
hustings how nervous were you it was a
liz trott's backer that she was going to
make it onto the final two because
things were really tight weren't they at
the end
it's been a really good debate and i and
you know like anybody else i was working
incredibly hard to try to support what i
thought was the best candidate to win
and i'm very pleased with today's result
but like john says there's a wealth of
talent in the party and that's another
thing that this debate has demonstrated
i would be looking forward to working
with my friend john and many others now
to make sure the party stays together
and focuses on the most important thing
which is forming the next prime
ministership to be able to serve serve
the country well it's it's interesting
it feels like we should reflect a little
bit on the tone of the debate uh doesn't
it and penny morgan coming under some
pretty sustained attacks on his trust uh
at points too along with richard cena
and how difficult do you think it's
going to be the conservative party to
effectively rebuild after obviously the
candidates ripping strips of each other
well penny was very clear from the start
of our campaign that she was going to
run a clean campaign i think at the end
of this process we can all hold our
heads high that that we have
done that equally i think it is right we
have a robust and energized debate
around the personalities she came under
some pretty sustained fire i mean david
davis for example wrote to simon casey's
cabinet secretary talking about leaks to
undermine her you had lord frost saying
that she was effectively incompetent had
to be moved there's a lot of people
speaking out against penny morgan penny
was responsible for her campaign her
campaign team of which i was very proud
to be parallel with a clean campaign we
are you can hold our heads high in terms
of how we can do do you think the
are being investigated now in terms of
the leak
uh and as i say it is right that we have
that type of robust discussion around
the offering at the end of the day the
person that wins this contest is going
to be the prime minister of our country
the two candidates remaining have to be
able to explain their policies have to
be able to get accountable to the
electorate and i think yes it's been
very energized yes it's been a bit
excitable and but that's a good thing
bit excitable that's one way of putting
it and there has been a bit of fire from
supporters of louis cross you know i
mentioned lord frost there uh who of
course worked with penny morden amy bit
of fire uh that way we've also of course
uh seen some attacks on russia soon act
by supporters of liz trust in douglas
smith for example it's telling me a few
moments ago that he does blame the
treasury under his leadership for
inflation do you think she's going to
tone it down or her supporters will tone
it down a bit going forward
i think the point is that uh individual
mps or peers in that case are more than
free to express their opinions and
clearly have done so we'll continue to
do so as now will the members as well
but actually elizabeth and her team have
been positive uh throughout and what we
really want to be able to do is have a
constructive debate based on a
conservative vision uh in the economy
based on what can be delivered from day
one for the country
for me the attractive point of
surroundings about elizabeth who i know
as a norfolk colleague and as a fellow
minister and a fellow mp is that she's
had that uniquely she has that breadth
of experience across departments which
will put her in a position to be able to
get things done my constituents from the
country and that is what i think is the
most positive and exciting thing that we
need to be able to secure
now i'm going to ask you this question
because i think you're most likely to
give me an answer on it because you're
neutral as a penny morgan supporter all
of the membership polling so far shows
liz class beating richie sooner do you
think that's now the most likely outcome
but she didn't know from honor i don't
know i mean it's very hard to call uh
party members because polling agencies
don't really know who the party members
are it's not like just canvassing or
following the general election party
members have to identify themselves and
most people members from my experience
don't necessarily take part in calls or
engage with uh on online
polls conservative home
during the course of this two week
campaigns i don't know before we may
just disagree but i think it's very hard
to tell what the membership ultimately
will decide well and i think it goes to
the the key point which is that you take
nothing for granted you work extremely
hard for what you hope to be able to
deliver and that is an issue
okay um the tony the debate next and
we're interested to get into is policy
because we do now have two very
different visions
for uh the uk
liz truster in particular talking about
a bold new economic plan if she wants to
change the policy that much shouldn't
she call an election to get a mandate
because every government has a mandate
we won an 80 seat majority um
just over two and a half years ago and
is right we i don't think the election
of the bank is having another election
this particular point in time is the
cost of living crisis they want this
conservative government to sort that out
to try and alleviate that as best we can
so i certainly would not be advocating
an early election uh the conservative
government has that mandate um at the
same time i just spoke to lynn fox who
was a supporter of rishi sunik who said
that actually ms trust should have an
eye on the last manifesto and if she
strays too far from it then you do have
to question the mandate
i think it's a reasonable point to want
to be able to deliver what we promised
the electorate at the last election
that's absolutely normal and reasonable
in politics and in fact what i know my
constituents want to see is the trust
they placed in me and through me and
conservatives should be repaid what i
think is also fair to point out though
is that actually in that time we've had
a pandemic a number of unexpected things
have happened in the life of the nation
and that does offer the opportunity to
take a fresh direction and i think that
will offer the opportunity to have that
debate on the best economic direction
from here to be able to build back
better out of the pandemic and make some
prosperity for everybody um do you know
who pay more that's going to back
any sneaking suspicions okay okay fair
enough
um and uh just finally uh would you like
to see if list trust wins would you like
to see what she's seen a companion all
day in the cabinet but his entire
decision for the next prime minister
whoever she may be certainly certainly
as i say you know we are very fortunate
in this body to have a lot of talented
people john uh included uh and uh what
that means is we need to be able to make
use of all of those um uh make use of
all those energies towards the goal of
serving the rich people okay thank you
both uh very much there uh john lemond
and clay smith talking about the need
for the conservative party to come
together uh after what's been a pretty
bruising conservative battle uh so uh
far well let's uh keep the debate going
shall we after now we now know the two
candidates who's made it through to that
all-important poll of the members we're
joined uh by our deputy
sam capes who's with us uh now i thought
was quite interesting talking to liam
fox you just dropped in that yes if uh
liz trusts uh donald wants to stray too
far with a new bold economic plan from
what was in the last manifesto then
maybe she should think about an election
and that of course is a scare tactic
because of course the one thing that
many victoria mps but more importantly
many members don't want to see the
general election just at the moment why
but we've seen double-digit leads in the
polls for the labour party we've seen
the labour party frankly
glory in the blue on blue attacks that
we've seen
between the candidates but what was also
interesting about leopards and and and
him saying that is that's just the first
hint about how this race is going to
change now
if you are
somebody running richard cena's campaign
i think you're going to pivot to an
argument that says there are two things
that you need to show you should need to
show that you can from the country and
the conservative person so when it comes
to running the country uh you will
emphasize experience
and a sort of common sense approach to
the public finances emphasizing that you
can't have something for nothing i think
that
they are they are going to put forward
it's a gamble as an argument it's not
always a terribly attractive argument
because they're going to hide that's
their that's their core pitch when it
comes to uh
beating
what will be interesting about liz trust
is just how much she wants to play up
the dividing lines with the current
government and that's what liam fox was
hinting at does she talk about the need
to deliver brexit
which will take us to quite a frosty
round with the european union uh could
she emphasize as she is emphasizing a
very different approach on managing the
economy essentially getting back to
paying down our debts later so that we
can fund uh various tax cuts up up front
but then you are straying further from
the mandate that delivered 80 seat
majority in 2019
and the further away you go from that uh
the closer you get to even people within
the conservative party suggesting it's
time to get to the country really
interesting sam uh we'll have lots more
from sam after the afternoon uh where's
all and now sam was just saying uh we
are only you know i guess uh what half
an hour after finding those final two
candidates but already we are starting
to see i guess the first sketches of
what to expect over the summer uh with
um liam fox talking about the mandate
from the last time round with in duncan
smith the liz trust supporter uh talking
about perhaps rishi sunak was
responsible uh for uh the economic
policy and the inflation that we've seen
uh recently well let's talk to mark
harper now shall we who's supporting
rishi suno
it's interesting isn't it we've ended up
after all of the roller coaster all of
the different ups and downs of the last
week or two with the two front runners i
guess the people you'd put your money on
at the beginning of the contest yes but
but i suppose if you say they're the
front runners it's not necessarily
surprising that that's where you get to
at the end of it but look it's going to
be a choice now for the party so there
are two two jobs that they're
effectively filling here in the same
person leader of the conservative and
unionist party and that's about winning
an election uh and all the polling says
that rishi sunaka's best place to win a
general election members care about that
and the second thing is they're very
conscious in seven weeks time they've
got to get a prime minister and a prime
minister that can deal with the economic
challenges and all of the other
challenges facing the country and
everything i've observed working with
rishi when i saw him working in the
treasury is that he is the right person
to deal with those challenges and i
think that's what will come out over
these debates so i'm looking forward to
the campaign for him getting out in
front of members and showing them
what he is about and i think they'll
conclude that he's the right person for
the job he's going to have to get out
there and show them isn't he because all
of the polling so far suggest that his
trust is going to beat him when it comes
to the members 20 point lead over rishi
sunak with uh ugar the conservative home
plot survey that's members as well and i
understand that their ups and downs it's
hard to pull members i know what you're
going to say but it's all pointing one
direction in the minute well it's it's
been all over the place actually the
coleman poll had had penny in the lead
and then it had kevin in the lead
the earlier polling at the beginning of
the contest did have rishi in the lead
actually it had him beating both liz and
penny in the members ballot look you
know polls are a snapshot not a
prediction the point about having
campaigns is we're going to have more tv
debates between just the two so i think
that will hone the choice down um
there'll be lots of sit-down interviews
with the personal journalists like
yourself asking tough probing questions
uh i think i think rishi will certainly
make himself available for those do you
think liz trussville she hasn't done a
broadcast interview yet well i hope so i
mean look this is a this is a choice for
our members if you want to be prime
minister of the united kingdom you've
got to be able to
do debates you've got to be able to do
broadcast interviews with serious
political journalists and you've got to
be able to take your message out if you
can't do those things uh the question
people are going to ask is can you be
prime minister so i think you're going
to be prime minister it's part of a job
description communicating and getting
out there and speaking directly to the
public is part of what's required in the
job so that's what i think both the
candidates are going to have to do over
the next seven weeks um and i know rich
is up for that and i think the more
people see all three and see them in
action the more they'll like what they
see so is that a commitment then if i
did host a debate over the summer the
head-to-head debate you'd like well i'm
not i'm not going to make commitments
we've had this conversation i think a
week ago and i'm not going to start
doing debate negotiations on the tv but
look he's he was in the first two
debates i think there was a general view
amongst our memphians that having
another debate when the electorate was
only 358 was a bit too much but i think
i understand rightly his campaign's been
clear i think that there's already a bbc
debate signed up for monday he he does
well in these debates i mean look he's
no reason for him not to do them the
first two debates we had he was judged
to have been the winner clear winner in
the itv debate and i think it was
between him and tom tugan out uh in the
channel 4 debate so he likes me i want
to talk a bit about the tone of the
contest so far because look i i think we
could all admit that we have seen uh
some
robust showing conversations between
rishi sunak and liz trusts are you
concerned that with these two going at
it over the summer that you know it
could be get pretty pretty messy well
it's two things first of all i think
there is going to be a proper debate
about policy because they clearly the
two of them clearly have different
visions about economic policy rishi i
think is being honest and
straightforward with people um i think
he'd love to be able to promise tax cuts
tomorrow but that's not realistic you've
got to deal with inflation that's what
mrs thatcher needs to deal with
inflation then you can deliver tax cuts
do you think that liz trust hasn't been
honest and straightforward well i don't
think what she's promising is a tall
deliverable that's what rishi said in
the debates that they had so that's
clearly going to be something we're
going to test over the next few weeks i
think on personal stuff with their own
personal qualities i think certainly
rishi will set out his qualities liz
will set up hers and then i think people
will have to judge them i don't think
they're going to start you know he's
certainly not going to start attacking
people personally but i think the two of
them now it's down to two would be very
mindful one of them's gonna win and then
we're all to have to get behind the
person that's elected legion and his
prime minister
as a conservative team a conservative
family and i think they're both going to
conduct themselves in that way certainly
russia's been clear when he launched his
campaign respectful campaign well he
called her he said that
well no he said the policies that she's
setting out are not realistic and
they're not realistic and i think being
prime minister
as he was one of those charts we've got
to tell people that tough truths i think
the public wants a prime minister that's
going to level with them about the
economic challenges we face and set out
the solutions and i think you get credit
in politics for being straightforward
and honest uh about some of the
difficulties rather than telling people
things they want to hear job of prime
ministers tell people
i guess what team trust would say in
response to that is look wishy sunic has
been in the treasury he's been
chancellor and look at the growth that
we've had look at inflation his policies
haven't worked so we need a change well
i think inflation is very clear it's the
unwinding of the massive shock to the
global economy from the pandemic
and a lot of the challenges on energy
prices and food prices are coming from
vladimir putin's war
in ukraine that's what's driving
inflation the real challenge and the
reason why you've got to slay inflation
fast so
so it doesn't become embedded in the
economy that's the real challenge that
we've got to deal with first uh just
finally i spoke to um excuse me okay
um uh i spoke to liam fox before you he
said if liz trust strays too far from
the last manifesto with her bold new
economic plan she should be thinking
about the mandate and you know hinting
at a general election there
well i think i think both candidates
have got to be very mindful the reason
why our system works the way it does is
we do have a majority in parliament the
reason why i think it's completely
legitimate to change prime minister's
mid parliament is because we elect
members of parliament and the prime
minister is the person that has their
confidence but we were elected on a
manifesto we need to deliver on that
manifesto
and that's what the uh and that's what
rishi wants to do but obviously mindful
of the changing circumstances but i
think we've made some promises to people
we've made some commitments and we've
got to keep him and that's about
restoring trust and that's his top
commitment uh in his campaign to become
prime minister okay mark harper thank
you very much uh indeed mark parker
there uh talking about the news uh that
rishi soon along with liz trust uh and
now uh on the alex uh our deputy air
political editor uh sam coats is with us
now well we just started to get the
first reaction haven't we um central
lobby has lit up
uh what even mp's been saying um well
listen i thought the most interesting
line is the one that just came from mark
harper a few seconds ago it came from
liam fox uh 20 minutes ago it almost
feels like it's an authorized line
within the rishi says to that campaign
which is to say that if the next prime
minister puts themselves forward on a
mandate for change
change that takes us too far away from
what the public voted for in the 2019
general election well then it might be
time to go to the country again this is
a bold move this is an interesting move
straight out of the traps we've actually
seen that camp having bought an argument
with which and let's make no bones about
it designed to scare people away from
voting for liz trust and when you think
about the differences between the two
candidates yes we've talked endlessly
for days about the tax differences and
uh basically liz trusters believe
that she can spend a bit more borrow a
bit more uh and uh therefore deliver tax
cuts immediately
uh uh so that that is the biggest
difference but there are lots of other
differences too certainly we'll be
hearing some of them now thank you sam
well in the last few moments we have
heard from uh the former chancellor now
through to the final stages of this
contest let's have a listen
the question now for our members is who
is the best person to defeat kierstama
in the labour party at the next election
i believe i'm the only candidate who can
do that and my values are also those of
our members and i've got the experience
and the vision to translate those values
into a government that delivers for the
british people and ensures that this is
the best country to live work and raise
a family anywhere in the world the
number of people you sat around the
cabinet table with have been criticizing
your economic policy are you surprised
to find so many think it's a terrible
policy
i've always said that i want to be
honest with the british people about the
challenges we face and be responsible in
dealing with them and people know my
track record i helped get this country
through an incredibly difficult period
over the last couple of years i made
sure that we supported those who needed
our help at every step with
interventions like the furlough that's
what people can expect from me going
forward and at a time of challenge i
think we need someone who's got the
experience to do that that's what i
offer but crucially for our members i'm
also the person who can beat kierstarma
in the next election and that should be
uppermost in their minds this morning
penny morden put out a tweet and then
deleted it which told mps that if the
final is rishi soon at versus list trust
then you'll murder the party that you
love what do you say to that yeah
this this contest has shown that the
conservative party actually has a
fantastic range of people in it all of
whom bring something exceptional and
different to the table i'm really
excited about the future of conservative
government in this country because of
that and i know that if i'm successful i
will try and build the team that draws
on all the talents and strengths in our
party because that's what britain
deserves so even though you said her
policies were socialist liz trust would
have a place at your cabinet table i
said this leadership contest has shown
that we've got fantastically able people
at the top of our party all of them
bring something exceptional to the table
but at this point the question for our
members is who is the best possible
person to beat kierstarma in the next
election and it's clear that i'm the
only candidate who can do that but can
you just address this
straight on be straight with us do you
regret the blue on blue attacks
kierstarma has just repeated that then
back to us people say it's a gift to
labour do you regret them and will they
stop
what we've seen is actually a debate
about ideas which is very healthy and
it's good for us to debate ideas to make
sure that we get the policies right for
the country now people have heard from
me a positive vision about what we can
do i'll tackle our problems with honesty
and responsibility i'll make sure that
we support people and make sure that we
grow our economy and take advantage of
the freedoms that brexit gives us but
crucially i am the person who is best
placed to beat kirst alma in the next
election and that's the question that
conservative party members now have that
a few times just finally have you been
lending votes to other candidates
absolutely not as you can see from the
results that have just been declared
this has been a really close contest and
i'm really humbled that i've made it to
the next stage i'm grateful to all my
colleagues for their support all i've
been doing all day today is talking to
them outlining my vision for the country
outlining how i'm the best person to
beat kierstarma in the next election and
i'm delighted that i'll now be able to
have that conversation with all our
members and hopefully convince them to
rush you sooner they're outlining his
reaction we can talk now to edward
argher liz trust supporter who joins us
now will she's soon out there making it
very clear that the polling shows that
he is more popular than liz trust with
the general uh electorate not the
conservative party members though
well i think liz has a